just 10 days shy of what would have been
her 55th birthday Lisa Marie Presley was
laid to rest welcome everyone to
Entertainment Tonight Kevin Frazier
joins us from Graceland Kev this was a
homecoming filled with heartbreak
Michelle heartbreaking is the perfect
word you know just think back to two
weeks ago Lisa Marie was right here on
the lawn at Graceland celebrating what
would have been Elvis's 88th birthday
and many of the fans who attended that
day came back for her memorial service
and so many great moments including
Alanis Morissette's fitting performance
of her song rest
foreign
slack and let her lie down
Lisa Marie Presley was an icon a role
model a superhero to many people all
over the world
my late mother-in-law used to say grief
is the price we pay for love
and how right she was
Oprah sent white roses and nearly five
thousand mourners gathered to say
goodbye to Lisa Marie in the second row
Elvis star Austin Butler he broke down
in tears during Amazing Grace girlfriend
Kaya Gerber comforted him but perhaps
the most heart-wrenching moment was this
I'm going to read something Riley wrote
Lisa Marie's daughter actress Riley
Keough was so overcome with emotion her
husband stepped in to deliver her eulogy
a letter to my mama I remember
everything
I remember you giving me baths as a baby
I remember all the notes you'd leave in
My Lunchbox every day
the eulogy included a surprise Riley and
Ben had recently had a baby girl making
Lisa Maria grandmother shortly before
her death I hope I can love my daughter
the way you loved me
survivors guilt some would say but a
broken heart was the doing of her death
Lisa Marie passed away two and a half
years after her son Benjamin committed
suicide motherhood is one of the things
that bonded her with close friend Sarah
Ferguson mothers losing children
it there are no words for it
I stand here with great honor because we
called each other [__] we've learned
that Lisa Marie became friends with
Fergie when she was living in England in
2010 they've stayed close and had spoken
just a few weeks ago cause nothing lasts
forever
muscle rolls delivered in other moving
performance singing November Rain he
told me Lisa Marie had wanted the song
played at her funeral your tribute was
so beautiful what did it mean to be here
and honor Lisa Marie I wanted to do
right by her and the family and and the
fans
so it meant a lot I was I was pretty
nervous and emotional up there she was
extremely proud as proud as anyone could
ever be of her father and his place in
music
Billy Corgan the front man of Smashing
Pumpkins in Lisa Marie's good friend LED
off the solo performances for a
star-studded crowd that included Evan
Ross Elvis director baz Lerman as well
as both of Lisa Marie's ex-husbands
Danny Keough and Michael Lockwood
the Blackwood Brothers quartet including
the son of Elvis's close friend Billy
Blackwood paid tribute to the king's
only daughter whom they met as a baby
Elvis How Great Thou Art was one of the
the songs that that he'd done just about
every show what did it mean to be able
to honor Lisa Marie
it was an honor and a privilege to be
invited to her memorial service
something I never thought we'd be
involved with but it was quite quite the
honor
Lisa's voice will only be Amplified with
time and never be silenced or diminished
it's still to an extent not real I mean
I was here 50 feet away with Lisa two
weeks ago Joe weinshanker president of
Elvis Presley Enterprises is still in
shock over the 54 year old's passing her
cause of death is deferred pending
toxicology which could take months Lisa
Marie spent some of her final days with
Joel the two celebrated her father's
88th birthday here at Graceland how was
she that last week it was by far the
best week of her life since Benjamin
passed she was happy she had an amazing
time at the Golden Globe she was so
happy that Austin won she said I'm gonna
I'm gonna eat my foot if Austin loses
the Presley family thank you guys Joel
says Lisa's last wishes for both her
Memorial and for Graceland have been
carried out it was Lisa's desire
without question that her children take
over it will be Riley's home uh without
question like I needed to be here
just wanted to show my respect and love
in one poignant moment we saw some fans
a few of whom got to Graceland as early
as 2 A.M hold up their programs adorned
with Lisa Marie's face in tribute they
joined the processional to the
meditation Garden where she was laid to
rest next to her son Benjamin there was
no question she wanted to be buried at
Graceland she wanted to be buried next
to her son the one thing she said is
just don't make it sad
foreign
[Music]